uh well don't don't blame the audience
don't berate the audience and a comedy
audience doesn't come to the show
to hate you okay comics a comedy
audience is not like
you know let's go to the comedy show
tonight and ruin that comic's life
what's goodie comics welcome to hot
breath the show where you learn comedy
from the pros
i'm comedian joel byers after 10 years
in this game and over 300 interviews
with the top comics in the industry i'm
here to share with you
all the tips i had to learn the hard way
so you don't have to
this is a great question sandy and
connecting with the audience is
something
that i will still have to be mindful of
and be listening to the audience because
it can be the difference between
you killing and bombing in a lot of ways
is you being
sensitive to the audience and how
they're responding to you you know
it's a conversation stand-up is a
conversation it's not a dialogue or a
monologue excuse me it's a dialogue
so you say something then the audience
laughing is their response
give them time to laugh and then you go
into your next joke
a big mistake young comics make is
talking through the laughs they don't
give the audience time
in the dialogue in the conversation they
don't give the audience time to speak
so sometimes if you're not connecting to
the audience is
because you're not listening to the
audience and a lot of times as younger
comics
something that young comics will do is
we're just thinking about the next joke
we're like alright i did that one all
right what's next on the set list okay i
did that one
what's next and you're you're not even
listening to the audience but the more
prepared you are
the more confident you are in your
performance and on your stage experience
which
takes time but also practice and
repetition off stage
the more you'll be able to listen to the
audience and be sensitive to how they're
responding
because i can tell you from personal
experience you know
coming up in atlanta i was known as
white boy joel so
i would get booked on shows just as the
white guy they just needed diversity
or an alibi in case the cops showed up
or whatever
so i remember i did a show at uptown
comedy corner here in atlanta and
i was doing well and then i said
i said something like i have race jokes
but i said something like
i think i improvised something racial
and it came off
weird but i just kept going i wasn't
listening to the audience i just kept
going
and then like two minutes later you
could feel the audience like
pulling away from you and i remember
i felt it and i and i just stopped for a
second
and i honestly like there's a table on
the front
at uptown there was a table where people
could sit but this was like a 12 30 show
there were not people at the front table
there were just some high and drunk
people scattered
about who wandered in for the 12 30 show
and i leaned on that table and i just
went
where did i lose y'all what
happened to us and i kind of i made a
funny moment of it it was like
we were so close and doing so well what
happened to us
and they all just kind of kind of
giggled and kind of like they were
interested again
they weren't being like just oh whatever
and texting they were like oh what's
happening here
because not all silence is bad silence
there's a difference between a bombing
silence and them listening
silence and engaging silence and then
i was like oh it's it's probably it's
that
weird race comment i made earlier wasn't
it yeah i didn't even mean to do that i
improvised that and i should know as a
white man don't improvise
in such environments i should just have
be happy to be here that y'all let me in
here and i kind of made fun of the fact
i was the only white guy in the area
code and who am i to even
think i could say something like that
and i basically addressed the elephant
in the room i addressed
that what i was doing wasn't working
maybe this is the reason why
this is actually something i heard deng
cook talk about before
is he was talking about early on in his
career he would have those moments where
it wasn't working
like the audience wasn't responding and
he literally would just ask them he's
like where did we go wrong
where did i miss you guys let's let's
figure this out together
and he was like it's not funny but it's
real
and that's how you really connect with
an audience is that real
so if you're not connecting with the
audience
ask them really genuinely ask the
audience like
where did i miss you what what has i've
worked hard on these jokes what's
missing right now
is it my delivery is it the writing is
it you
uh well don't don't blame the audience
don't berate the audience and a comedy
audience doesn't come to the show
to hate you okay comics comedy audience
is not like
you know let's go to the comedy show
tonight and ruin that comic's life
no they want to come and laugh so don't
berate the audience
but that being said i have done shows
where they do come to laugh and jingle
their keys at you and boo you and all
that
but that's beside the point overall
fans and comedy goers come to laugh and
they want to laugh and if
if it's missing they feel it too so
address it
just be genuine and curious about it and
it'll be scary at first
but the more you do it the easier it'll
get and that's just a fun tip that's
helped me to become more
present and real on stage and to help me
to listen
to the audience more i hope you found
that helpful this clip you just watched
is actually from our q a we do in our
facebook group where we also do a daily
joke writing contest so if you want to
write more jokes and connect with more
comics
click the link in the description of
this video
and i'll see you there we got some good
good goods don't we